the script and
here we go as chairman of division two
of the house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
and as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting today
we will be voting on several
issues that we need to
come to grips with prior to finalizing
the budget
and also i plan to spend
some time on the statewide entity
to receive complaints out alleging
misconduct regarding sworn
and elected law enforcement officers and
that's on that commission
all members of the committee oops please
note there's no
fiscal location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order one
i am confirming all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability
to communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information
has been made available through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email
lba underscore fiscal
at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll paul let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative lin would you call the
role please
yes uh thank you madam chair uh
representative porter
i'm here in hillsborough um in my home
my husband
is in the house but not in the room with
me thank you representative turcotte
i'm in my home in barrington my wife is
in the house at in her office
thank you representative heath good
morning and happy st
patrick's day to everybody out there um
i'm mary heath
and i'm here in manchester in my home
and i'm home alone
thank you i'm bob lynn i'm here at my
home in windham
i'm in the room alone but my wife is
elsewhere in the house
representative murray kate murray is
here in newcastle
i'm alone in my office david's in the
house i think he's in his office
thank you representative petry
representative petrie is in the uh
in his home in farmington with a dog in
a house and
in the house yeah right and the wife
romigna halls
thank you and representative umberger
yes good morning i am uh
in my home in kearsarge and um
my husband is in the house but not in
the room
all right thank you okay thank you all
i guess we have that part memorized
right
so um
mickey has prepared some uh
documents for us and um
i'd like to um
the um at the top
of the the list that's called
changes from the governor's recommended
um
mickey on this do you wanna do we want
those up or does everybody have them
handy
i have it okay it looks like we've all
got our
got our paper and it is anyone that
wants it it is available
on the lba website
under division two documents so if
you're interested in looking at those
um that's it so uh
mickey would you explain the uh
number one the safety sure
so this year this
kind of compiles everything that
agencies have kind of put on the record
with their presentations as far as
request
changes to their budget um as well as
some other changes that have been made
so far those are shaded in gray so
starting right off the bat um la in row
number one safety's additional
prioritized needs if you recall
um as part of their budget presentation
the department had
i believe it was close to 60 separate
items
that they had ranked in a priority order
for
the division to consider because they do
have a mixed funding
situation at the department of safety
you'll see this request
spread out between line row 1 rule 14
and row 22.
this is the uh the total of all i think
it was 59
prioritized requests so that's what the
safety additional prioritized needs
represents
okay so these were the uh the extra
uh forensic people yeah so all the
positions they requested
uh there was some other i mean i think
there was some facility maintenance
money at one of the requests
i'd have to pull the list but there it
was expensive as you remember quite a
few positions
uh to be funded was the lion's share of
their requests
okay so uh i think we better hold off on
this one
until we see what's uh
what's going on with the general fund
so representative murray you have a
question
yes thank you just so i understand so
the
total of what safety is requesting
across these three agencies
is around the total is around 10 to 11
million
if i'm looking at one and 14
and 22 or yeah if you add all that would
fund 100
of their requests that's around between
10 and 11 if i'm adding really fast
between those three actually it's
general highway and then that other is
the combination of several other sources
of funds but yes
in total funds it's around 10 11 million
thank you
yeah so mary i'm telling you you gotta
water that and fertilize it
okay uh the next two items there are
um full funding for um
the community college and uh the
university system
and i'm going to
pass over those as well at this point
um i would
you know i would love to be able to uh
provide additional money but i i just
don't
uh the education
is looking for two million dollars
for a student information data system
again a worthy cause
um but i don't i don't see us
um the next one
is a hundred and eight thousand
to move a position from federal funds to
general funds
mickey do you want to talk to us about
this one oh i'm sorry mary
our representative heath you have a hand
up um i just i
just wanted to say that i did agree with
you about that line in education
i think um now is not the time to do
that
so um i think that we will agree with
you on that
so so this was one of the requests that
the department of ed had brought forward
that they have a position that's
currently in a federally funded
accounting unit
in the governor's recommended budget and
they are seeking to
reload relocate that position to be
funded through general funds
they i think testified that um
that position could not be funded where
it is now and they're just seeking to
keep it existing
or keep it up an existing position but
it would just move to general funds so
to do this change if you look at line 33
down below we would reduce the federal
fund
appropriations in the budget and
increase general funds so this would be
about a
225 000 increase to your general fund
uh spending if you were to approve this
item
and we don't we don't have that in the
host bill one amendments
separate document today so that's just
for you to be aware of and if
as an example if any of these items
someone on the committee wishes to make
a motion and you know i want to fund
this i want to
you know i think the chair will
accommodate that i can also prepare for
you
kind of a specific sheet similar to the
house bill one items i sent to last
night
for any of these agency requests
yep i i agree but um
i think we're we're all cognizant of
where the
uh where the general fund stands and
work and uh i don't know
whether any of that money will
come to division 2
or if it will all go to division 1
and division 3 which have much larger
um general fund requirements
than we do but again we may
i don't i don't want to take them off
because surprise you know mary's money
tree
comes through for us so representative
heath you have a question
oh thank you um mickey did the
department give you a rationale of why
they wanted to move that
position is it they have to show
maintenance of effort or
is there a sound reason i i
i can double check with them they
brought this up to the the committee
when they are before us as one of their
requests i can look back at the item i
don't know if it just had to do with
there's not the federal money
there to fund that position they
expected but they wanted to keep the
position or
uh it could have just been it was just
inappropriately funded in the wrong area
to begin with so
i can get that information for you and
um and follow back up
i yeah my my question was really sort of
basically along the same line as
representative heath just asked
the the only thing uh mickey that would
concern me
is um if the
if if the situation was that this was a
federally funded position that
the the person in the position wasn't
really
doing what the federal requirements
sort of required and you know that
safety
sort of didn't didn't want to get rid of
the person but was
so was just sort of finding a job for
them with uh
with general funds if so in other words
what i'm saying is
i would be interested to know if it's
really necessary
to have this position because if it's
not then that you know that
makes a difference i think yep i will uh
i'll certainly reach out to them to get
a further explanation of
of why this request has come forward
whether it's
um was truly a um
a budget mistake i guess when they
loaded the budget and put the position
in the wrong area
or if it is uh something beyond that so
i'll get i'll get additional info for
the committee
okay thank you thank you very much uh
okay uh the net
mickey i thought you were putting things
on here that we could all agree with
well i do have those um on the next the
next document so
this is a good document just to this is
a kind of our entire
universe so to speak we've got a house
bill 2 document as well that captures
everything
this is really all the requests for
budget changes here so there's going to
be some tough items here to discuss
you're not going to probably get through
them today
um but this at least i hope will
help the committee members to kind of
get a grasp of the full picture here
that was the idea of these
okay um the next one is
um external support for the new board of
trustees for unification plan
again until we decide where
we stand on the unification plan i
okay additional uh prioritized needs
from transportation
we've already covered the safety mickey
is this money within
this request here the additional
prioritized needs the department brought
forward would be all highway funds
so this is a money for equipment this is
other
maintenance efforts that they had
brought forward that they would like to
fund in the next two years the
conway bypass payback would be included
in this this is just all their
additional
funding needs that are not currently
included in the budget
okay so and and there's not sufficient
dollars in the highway fund to cover
these
no i mean as of right now with the
actions that have taken place to this
point
um we're about one and a half million
one point six million dollars in the
deficit
the committee had discussed uh winter
maintenance line as a place to
address that as a way to balance the
highway fund
i'm carrying that down below on this
document if you see at the very bottom
just other
items to consider so if the committee
wants to
explore that at another time i don't
have a change sheet prepared for that
today
but i know that's something that the
committee had discussed as an area to
this is in fish and game oh mary d i'm
sorry representative heath did you have
a question
thank you madame chair just a quick
question um to mickey
um if we were to use that winter
maintenance money
um
so it ultimately would mean that the
accounting unit with the appropriations
to fund the winter maintenance
operations
would be reduced by i mean just using
round number probably eight hundred
thousand dollars a year from the
governor's level
it would still have it funded at a
higher level than we've had in the last
few budgets
and the department still has their
existing statutory authority to come to
fiscal
and request funds from the highway fund
if there are
any available to cover any shortfalls
they have in that area come
the realizations of a winter so
it's somewhat business as usual for
budget writers in the last uh
few terms but even after a reduction
that we would need to do
to balance the highway fund for division
two it's still a higher appropriation
level than
has been in the last few budgets so that
that's a good place for us to work from
tonight
thank you mickey i i
was just a little confused by what you
said
when you say it's it would be a higher
appropriation
for equipment nope and i'm sorry winter
not equipment okay i'm sorry yeah okay
this would all be a winter maintenance
um is what i'm referring to
with that reduction that we had talked
about
okay so um we could balance the highway
fund with winter maintenance
and still have a little bit leftovers is
that
even the the net budget that would
remain after the reduction you would
need to balance the highway fund is
still a
healthy appropriation level compared to
prior budgets
we also i don't think it's in the
package today
but dot has
asked for authority
to use any extra lapse money
to fund winter maintenance
so i'm sorry i don't i don't know what
the lapse number
is right now it's in one of the pieces
of paper that we have here
um but if they lapse
more than that then they would want to
put it
against uh equipment
so um we'll that's just something
else to put in your brain uh
in regards to um funding
equipment for um d.o.t
and we do have representative that
amendment is in the house bill 2 packet
that i sent out last night oh it is
yeah we do have that to discuss when we
get to house bill 2 today if you'd like
okay all right but i i just wanted to
let everybody know and of course
who knows what the lapse is going to be
okay uh fish and game
a hatchery manager petition a
position and um
we did get a letter from
fish and game asking for this to occur
go ahead representative heath um i just
think the fishing game
thank you madam chair fishing game is
healthier than it's ever been
i think they have a revenue that if they
want to fund this position
that they just take it out of their own
little budget
but can i answer one more question too
while we're talking about dot
they have a really high um a really high
uh
amount that has to go to um
the doit um and i just um
i'm not asking that right now but just
something that i would like to inquire
about
thank you yeah and oh by the way
they're going to be given a larger piece
what do we what do we want to do with
um this uh
unfunded hatchery manager position
represent murray thank you i agree with
representative heath i think this money
is maybe better used in
many other places and they are healthy
um
it seems to me they should be able to
fund it themselves
just to clarify this request for the
department of the fishing game
department is to use their federal and
their fish and game funds to fund it so
so can i share my screen representative
i know we all have the documents but it
may be easier for me to
share just so everyone's clear what
we're talking to at each time
sure
so hopefully you all can see the pdf
here for the
hb1 amendment requested by fish and game
not yet
can you see it yes okay
so this was in the packet that i sent
out to everybody last night so this kind
of breaks down what the fish and game
department is looking to do
um so you can see
the source of funds for this request are
federal and 25 or close to a fish and
game funds so
the the net impact to the fish and game
fund is very small
they have a healthy surplus right now a
healthy budget um
so i to me there's not a whole lot to
this request
i'll move that motion to approve that
line okay thank you
we'll not use any general funds thank
you
uh joe did you second that i sure did uh
i do
i do have a question when you get ready
okay
so um we have a first of a motion in a
second
uh go ahead with your question i thank
you madam chair uh
does this take care of the pollution
problem at the uh
i don't think so representative
uh there is a letter that's also in this
attachment that i sent last night that
was previously sent by the department
explaining
what i don't think it's relative to
that thank you
yeah it's uh it's not
it's not um
so representative lynn would you uh call
the role
please
yes uh hang on one second let me just
get my little form here
all right all right and so this is on
funding that currently unfunded
uh fish and game position
that's correct that's correct all right
um
so uh uh representative petry
petri vocias all right
um uh whoops representative
uh uh turcotte
turcotte votes yes thank you
uh uh representative lin votes yes
um representative porter representative
uh representative heath heath beauchess
representative murray very votes yes
and representative umber uh represent
ambergris
all right uh the vote is seven to zero
in the affirmative
okay thank you
the three items for education
on the bottom i think is um
you know we've talked about a couple of
them
but right now we're just gonna have to
um
pass over those well i i will just
clarify
these are other funds so the first one
the credentialing
is 100 paid for from the credentialing
fund that the commissioner had brought
forward with their
restructured budget request as well as
adding a position
in that area and then the next growth 32
is the department's awarded grants has
been awarded grants from the governor's
commission on alcohol
and other drugs and they missed the
budget they had multiple grants one of
them was already in the budget these two
didn't get put in so they're just asking
to
recognize these uh other funded grants
so there's no general fund impact to
these
these these first two okay
and when i so i'll show you the
this this is the picture and the change
that they're looking to do for
credentialing
and we can start with that one first or
you could do them
in a block if you want and then here's
the requests for the um
grants that were that missed the budget
that they'd like to add in
so as you can see transfers from other
agencies
there's no general funds impacts here
there's no state funds same thing with
credentialing this is all from
sorry about that it looked really good
so
well mickey doesn't want to screen share
with us
but i i uh i can tell you these are in
the
the packet that i sent to everybody last
night and they are online too if anyone
listening is is looking for
yeah i don't know for some reason
it's no it's we understand it
uh representative heath um i would be
comfortable moving
the motion for number 31 the
position funded um in credentialing
um i do know that credentialing should
be
pretty healthy uh we i did ask for an
amount
that they have um in that line but i
never did get a response from the
commissioner on that
but um from my prior knowledge that that
was something that
there's always plenty of funds there and
the other position
the um position
[Music]
the governor's commission on alcohol and
um i would add that too
add the uh position for and for
uh credentialing and the
governor's commission on alcohol grant
funds
second admiral if i may um
[Music]
i think i could add the um
the request from the doe to
include in the budget those federal
lines that they had omitted am i saying
this right mickey
uh which which federal lines is that
well they were
they had a request to add um
uh dollars that they hadn't listed in
their
um original request or am i i'm you know
maybe i should just go
for those two positions we'll just leave
with that one so the
credentialing change and then the the
two from the governor's
alcohol and drug uh governor's
commission on drug and alcohol fund are
the only two that i'm aware of for now
that's fine yes thank you that's the
motion
okay thank you uh
representative lynn are we doing okay
[Music]
i'm sorry we're talking about items 31
ad position and other funding and
credentialing and item 32
add government governors commission on
alcohol grant funds is that correct
that's correct all right all right thank
you
all right um representative uh petry
victory votes yes all right um
representative turka perkavoz yes
uh representative lin votes yes
um representative porter 400 votes yes
thank you representative heath heath
votes yes
representative murray murray votes yes
and representative umber um
representative hamburger votes yes
all right seven to oh uh in the
affirmative madam chair
okay thank you very much okay mickey
what's our next
i think at this point as long as
everyone's comfortable and understands
everything we just went through that's
kind of everything that's in play
that's been discussed in the committee
at this time um
and i know i've been working with some
members on some house bill 1 amendments
for future work sessions
and i'll update this document as we meet
to shade what we've already approved add
some new ideas that you know anyone
wants to bring forward so this will be a
working document we'll update each time
i think now we can go to the file that i
sent that was called
hb2 tracking document which is
uh essentially lists all of the existing
house bill 2 sections
as well as some amendments that were
sent out last night as well to consider
i'd love to share my screen because i
think it would help but zoom's not
cooperating today
for some reason so i'll try one
but it is the one that at the top says
hb1 slash hb2
sections to consider oh is the screen
working now looks like it might be
yes it is okay
so we can go through each of these if
you'd like
and there's quite a few that i feel the
committee has had
consensus on and probably not going to
offer any amendments or changes to
what's already in the bill
and those could be ones that the
division wants to take up today to at
least
have them behind us i've got a super
easy one to start with
if you'd like so for those that have
been on the committee before in
the back of house bill 1 one of those
back of the budget sections there's some
boilerplate language for the lottery
commission to have authority to
essentially purchase their tickets that
they sell
it's never a section that we've ever
really changed it provides the
authority for them year after year it's
a like i said it's a boilerplate
budget section it resides on page 717 of
the house bill one document itself that
we
aren't even really working from right
now um section four
so customarily we when we have a section
that we're not going to want to change
we would usually still vote and say
accept it as it is you know or no change
or
however you want to word it
representative burger
that way it'll let us know when we
assemble these bills later
for the finance committee we know what's
in and what's out
is there a reason why this has never
gotten into statute
no it it's just always been in house
bill one and
it's uh it's got a fixed dollar amount
that
you know it changes each budget but it's
uh it's kind of just been the general
authority that lottery
has outside of the budget to purchase
their ticket stock
okay uh could i have a motion
to authorize
the back of the
budget item on the lottery to
be there so moved thank you
second petri representative petrie thank
you
oh mickey you probably shouldn't have
no the screen sharing i could tell
wasn't working again i'm just trying to
troubleshoot what's going on here okay
okay uh representative lynn whenever
uh thank you uh that way and that was
moved by murray
and seconded by petrie is that correct
that's correct
all right um all right thank you um so
uh representative petry
representative turka representative
turcotte votes yes
uh representative lin votes yes uh
representative porter
order votes yes representative heath
keith photias representative murray
murray votes yes representative umber
representative umberger votes yes all
right the vote is seven to zero
okay um no this is
um in hb2
page 44 or page 22
this is uh doe is allowed to
accept uh gifts
for the um the new hampshire scholar
program
correct is there does anyone have a
yes representative heath thank you
madame care the only problem i have is
there's no funding in that line
um but um i would i would uh make a
motion
um to allow for the department of
education
to accept gifts for the um state
scholars
program thank you uh do i have a second
uh mary i think that's just a line that
they have to leave
or the area they have to leave open and
in case your money tree is working right
thank you okay representative lin when
you're ready to uh
call the role yep give me one second
motion by heath and seconded by circa
all right um uh representative
uh uh petrie representative petri voce
yes
representative turca representative turk
on voces
um representative lin votes yes
uh representative porter votes yes
representative uh heath
youth butches representative murray
murray votes yes and representative
umberger
representative humberger votes yes all
right so
7-0 vote in the affirmative okay
representative i'm going to switch to
andrea to share a screen because
my zoom's giving me problems i can
already tell i can't scroll up and down
or go to pages for the committee so
i'm gonna step out here and let andrea
share the same document we were just
okay
sorry about that i don't know what's uh
what the challenge is for me today but
there is one well
here's the deal mickey it's always a
challenge
maybe you should have worn green that's
true i thought my first name was enough
but i guess not
[Laughter]
in my house we always turn it off and
turn it back on and
it works thank you andrea
um so i'd say the next the next sections
in house bill 245 and 46 are relative to
the calculation of adequate education
grants
i don't think we're probably getting
into that today
so we can probably skip skip that
representative
i think that's a very good idea okay
i would go down yeah i would go down to
number 30.
okay we do have an amendment possibly
that could impact uh
line 20 or page 22 section 47.
so in house bill 2 now there's
an edit to the education trust fund
revenue in that
if tobacco settlement funds are less
than 40 million dollars a year
which is the case it just makes it clear
that
that's the amount that goes to the
education trust fund it's nothing more
than a clerical
technical change that the governor's
office recommended putting in there and
we agree with
um the only reason i say to bring this
one up is
you can either accept it as is or in
your amendment packet
amendment number zero six nine three
h amends this section if you recall one
of the things that
um division two is going to have to
address
is to allow for the education trust fund
to be used for school building aid
tuition and transportation aid
special education aid as we did in the
current budget
last year in house bill 2 that authority
was only granted for the biennium only
the budget does the same thing this time
around out of the governor's office and
likely will add a division two
so we need to amend house bill 2 to
allow for this
there's two amendments that do this one
codifies it
and makes it so this change will be in
perpetuity
that's amendment zero six nine three h
zero six
nine four h does what we did last time
and makes that
authority for the biennium only so
you would only as a division recommend
one of those
it really comes down to do you want that
the education trust fund to be used for
these programs for the biennium only or
in perpetuity
okay so what you're saying is that we
could in fact
um vote on
yep and you would uh vote on 47
to change it to make that change that i
was just talking about statutory it
would amend this section because 47
affects that same section of law or
um just put it in a chapter law for two
years if you want that
authority for me two years only so it's
really
up to the committee what policy you want
to set for using the education trust on
representative heath um actually i think
representative maru was before me
oh i'm sorry representative murray oh
thank you it's all it does either way is
fine with me
i'm just having a hard time parsing
lines 34 35 and 36 it doesn't seem to be
is it written correctly
is there something that's not here that
i'm supposed to know about from another
document
but i don't understand frankly the
sentence to be
blunt now
can someone tell me what document you're
looking at please
hp2 thank you yeah
what it what it's saying is that
if um the tobacco settlement
has been 40 million
for many years however
if it's less than 40 million
we still want to accept that money
into the education trust fund
so even if it's less than 40 million all
that money goes to
the trust fund that's correct is that
what it says
i think that's yes i think i think
that's what it says
so the law is 40 million goes to the
education trust fund anything
extra would have gone to the general
fund the total amount now is anticipated
to be less than 40.
so this just clarifies it won't be 40.
it'll either be 40 or whatever the
actual amount is so it just provides
clarification that because i think it's
like we're at 37.9
is what the revenue estimates have for
the uh tobacco settlement this time
so it's just clear that it's not always
going to be 40 it'll be
either 40 or whatever the actual amount
is okay thank you it's hard for me to
representative heath um thank you madam
chair so
it just means that it will
go on as usual to the trust fund
only the amount is not the 40 million
it's that simple yeah there's no actual
change to this it was a
i think a technical recommendation from
the comptroller's office is my
understanding of where the section
okay so um could i have a motion to
accept uh
do i just need the section 47 well and
this is this is where it's up to
representative do you want
because if you do want to make that
education trust fund change i was
talking about statutory it would amend
the same law as section 47 so we would
just
merge it into section 47. so
do you does the committee want to make
the education trust fund
uses open for the biennium only or make
that a
statutory change moving forward that's
what it comes down to and then
we would do one of those two amendments
vicky would you say that again please
sure yeah mickey i think i think at this
point
we will just vote on 47
okay and then we'll
um
we'll look at 48
but um i think this one is easy no
no go ahead representative
yes thank you uh that's uh chairman
i've previewed both of the amendments
that mickey's talking about and i i
would actually like to see
uh 0.693h in there
so i don't know if we have to you know
pass 47 first or go straight to the
amendment but i'd like to propose that
one please
so that amendment does include the
underlying section 47
so that would be essentially supporting
which i think everyone agrees with and
then that that amendment makes the
education trust fund change statutory as
far as opening up its uses so
yep so that would be that would be a
proper
idea we would plug in that amendment
here yep okay so what was the amendment
number
okay i thought i had all this in one
uh representative porter
yes thank you madam chair i guess i'm a
little confused
so when we're looking at this document
that's on the screen now
we're looking at page 22 section 47
education trust fund we have to approve
that that's in the current budget is
or we can approve it via
one of two amendments
that that change i guess i'm confused of
what we do do we have to do 47 first
or can we do 47
just do the amendment no we do not
do not what we do not have to approve 47
because the
amendment that representative turcotte
is referring to right um
includes both the tobacco settlement
and the um
the public school business dealing with
uh
um right the the fund itself
so and i think i understand that but if
we decide against
both of these amendments do we still
have to go back and approve
47. that's my question
we have to do something with
that line yes
um the structure of
the education trust fund okay
we either make it for two years
or we make it statutory okay
it represents
you said zero six three nine
are you sure no zero six
nine three h okay okay
thank you my ears were uh my ears were
backwards
uh representative heath um
thank you madam chair let's just talk a
little bit
about the implications of that so
in the last session we had
um a lot of money
in the trust and and
we were in great shape and it was a
fabulous use of those funds to do
building aid
um special ed costs and tnt
and it worked really well in the year
when there are many years when the
education trust
does not have those funds and it has to
draw
funding from the general fund
so just thinking ahead
what lawmakers will have to do with
future budgets
i just am not sure um
[Music]
of making that change permanent
i mean it has advantages and
disadvantages
it protects building aid
and special ed aid and tnt
but at the same time trying to balance a
budget
and making sure we have sufficient funds
i just am not sure of the implications
of codifying that um as a permanent
change
yeah i i have no problem going either
way
and i think representative heath makes
some
make some good points um
representative do you have any problem
um i do not i just preferred the uh
zero six nine three
yeah well if you know if i would
i would prefer that as well but i
believe that representative heath has
made
an excellent point that um
we may not in the future have sufficient
uh education trust funds
to manage everything that were um
that we're talking about but so anyhow
um
representative murray did your hand up
i did i was just going to ask quickly if
would this be something that we could
consider
in the next year so that we have time to
consider what representative heath was
yeah i mean this is uh if if we do it
temporarily
we can always submit a bill because
there's really no money tied to it
you can always submit a bill to make it
permanent
and the only other thing i'll clarify is
these
these amendments make it allowable for
the education trust fund to be utilized
for these programs it doesn't require
budget writers fund these programs from
the education trust fund because
under current law there's explicit
uses for the education trust fund so
like you
you'd have to change law to use it this
just provides
it opens it up a little bit but
certainly in house bill one you could
still fund these programs with the
general fund if you wanted to you're not
required to
representative lynn you had a question i
i'm i'm sorry i'm i'm
i'm a little bit confused i guess i
don't
um
i understand that that the the issue
that we're we're sort of debating
is whether we approve this for just the
biennium or
permanently i guess what i'm not clear
where does it say one or the other i'm
that that's the thing i'm guessing
i'm a little confused about this is the
two amendments representative
so amendment uh zero six nine
three puts it right into rsa um
a 1 98 39 whatever it is whereas the
other one
is just a session law for the biennium
only so you would only adopt one of
these two amendments depending on which
policy you want to set here
and mickey what's the second amendment
number
zero okay
yeah i know i see it now i'm sorry i see
uh representative heath uh thank you
ma'am care okay i just want to clarify
so
in my mind i have the right
so amendment 0693h
allowable uses for the education trust
it does not require that to happen year
after year
but it allows for am i correct mickey
correct it it opens up the allowable
uses for the education trust fund but
it's really all driven by what we
appropriate in house bill 1 the source
of funds
a follow-up please please
compromise the trust fund
and open it up to other uses that we
have not clarified
no no i mean so it's it
essentially uses the same language we
use last term it just
under current law we can use it for
adequacy the low and moderate homeowners
property tax relief program and any
other kindergarten programs
established by the general court this
opens it up to be for
tuition and transportation special ed
aid and school building aid that's it
there's no other uses that in the budget
you could do without changing that law
all right thank you
representative porter thank you madam
chair
previous to last term budget
those items listed here came from the
general fund then
okay
so uh representative turcotte
moved amendment
zero six nine three
um do we have a second on that
second by petri okay thank you
so uh this is
yeah we're going to vote on amendment
2021 0 6 9
47 and
48 no yeah 47
and 48 uh mickey no just 47 but it takes
care of
your issues okay all right so this takes
as as well as the other stuff that
wasn't
um uh necessarily a problem
right so representative lynn would you
call
would you call the role or are there any
other questions
okay i don't see any okay representative
flynn are you ready to call the role
i am yes uh uh motion made by
representative turcotte and uh seconded
by representative petry
um uh representative petrie
petrie votes yes representative turcotte
turcotte uh representative lin
votes yes um representative porter
what are votes yes representative heath
heath vote yes representative murray
marie votes yes and representative umber
representative amberger vote yes
ma'am chair the vote is seven to zero in
the affirmative
okay thank you
um
let's go down to number uh
page 30 number 68
which is the crisis intervention
uh training uh
this money appeared in both
hb1 and hb2
and what this is doing is um
taking it out of or what we want to do
and leave it in hb1
and mickey do we have to
at the same time approve a
footnote in hb1 or do we do that
someplace else
we could do it now as is just one motion
to remove house bill 2 and add the
footnote to house bill 1.
so amendment 0712h from your amendment
packets
has the straight delete of this section
and then if you look at the following
page in
the packet that i sent you see the
language
of the footnote that we would add right
to that appropriation where the line is
in
police standards budget that way it's
clear that that appropriation
is still for this purpose but uh
we just keep it all combined in one bill
versus
doubling it up it was a it was really a
technical mistake
in the way the documents came to us so
okay are there any questions on this um
you know just
one question manager mickey could you
give me the amendment number one more
time
thank you
uh representative heath thank you madam
chair again just to uh
make sure i know what i'm voting for
it's simply a
a correction of a duplication of house
bill one
and 2 and moves that section to
hb1 only that's correct
just kind of a fix it up okay right
thank you madam chair i just want to
tell everybody that i feel official now
i just got my hb 1 and hp
2 on the nail it just got delivered so
now i'm official
thank you okay
i'm trying to i'm trying to get official
here which is kind of hard
um so could i have a motion
on that please i'll move
and that was represent porter i'll
win oh okay representative lynn all
right
all right seeing none representative
lynn when you're ready
to call the role thank you madam chair
uh representative petry
representative petri votes yes
representative turca
der cut boss yes representative lin
votes yes
uh representative porter
order votes yes representative heath
keith vocess representative murray
murray votes yes and representative
umber
represent hamburger votes yes all right
it's a vote of seven to zero in the
affirmatives
amendment zero six
nine four we can get rid of is that
correct
okay i just want to i just want to keep
okay um well
this is uh page 47
[Music]
this is um
wildlife this is on bears
damaged by bears where um
fish and game will uh take care of
whatever it is so um
are there any and by the way this came
back from
um fishing game as
representative heath thank you madam
chair
i just need to know what this means
mickey
it's just basically paying
for landowners i guess i should say for
and the funds for which this will come
are the fish and game funds am i correct
on that
yeah there's no there's no general funds
involved here this is all from their
dedicated sources
all right thank you okay
yes i don't know if you guys have
discussed this in committee already i
know i kind of parachuted in
a few days ago had this bill or this
section been discussed within committee
yet
uh no uh basically any time
that there is a
policy issue that um
that goes that is in hb2
we send it to the policy committee
for their review and they come back
and tell us whether they like the policy
or they don't like the policy
and in this case fish and game came back
and said
they liked the policy
this is standard that we've been doing
for years and years because we are
committee
did that answer your question not really
but
well yeah it doesn't doesn't um i guess
when yeah when fish and game was in
um did they talk about this it did not
okay but obviously they had no problem
with it either
no and and i did reach out to see
whether this was in or not if it would
result in any budgetary change needed
and they said no
so this purely is a policy section or
three sections and um
it's not uncommon that sections like
this will appear in house bill 2
and i think representative amber hit the
nail on the head usually the policy
committees do
uh a pine on whether or not they think
it's fine or not
and um i think the fishing game chair
did
this is just out of curiosity do we know
why this section was added into the bill
was there a problem with bears and
was blossoming in the last year or two
yes okay thank you
okay uh representative did you have
another question
i did it kind of i know it's
probably not directly relevant but did
did they mention
i mean how frequently does this happen
in terms of what
are they expecting the actual dollar
no i there was uh
there was nothing mentioned in that uh
in that regard
by anybody either fish and game or
um well
uh let's see
um represent porter did you have another
question no madam chair i'm sorry
representative lin i believe you were
next
uh yes you know what my my only question
about fear is this uh
um i i guess i
questions about the policy that i think
maybe representative porter and
representative turcotte
also have but i i understand that our
role is not the policy
role at this point so i i guess my
question is am i understanding that
if we vote to approve this on the sort
of money
issues thing um that's all we're doing
we're not saying that we necessarily
agree with the policy that um
i mean eventually when it gets to the
floor we're gonna we're gonna make a
vote that
uh that i guess include would include
both
things but right now we're only
approving this the
money aspect of it and there really
isn't any money aspect of this all
coming out of the
fish and game is that is that correct uh
no
because fish and game has told us
that this is good policy and so
what we're doing is within hb2
we are not only putting in the policy
and agreeing that fish and game is
doing whatever they need to do as well
as
any money that um
that the fish and game fund
may in fact need to expend
so anything that ends up in
hb2 okay whether it's
policy or money
is the recommendation from
our committee to
big finance along with uh
eventually to the house for their vote
so it's uh
you know it's both
i guess is my thought process on that
representative heath
thank you madam chair so the fishing
game
this was not generated by fishing game
oftentimes agencies will
provide any house bill 2 requests that
they have
to the governor during the development
of the governor's recommended budget so
this was deemed something from the
governor's office as okay to put in
there
as something that fish and game was
looking to have changed rather than
a separate bill as you all know that a
lot of times agencies will reach out to
members to draft a piece of legislation
in this case it was something brought to
the governor's office and just add it to
house bill 2.
um men of chair by may absolutely
um you know there's never been a public
hearing on this
there's never been a conversation really
about this
i just don't feel comfortable um going
forward with this
amendment i think it it needs to reside
in fish and game
and there needs to be um a little bit
more action
there are a number of things in hb2 that
haven't had public hearings
and it makes me very concerned and this
is one of the areas as well
now that i i i'm understanding what this
means a little bit better
so i i don't think i'm going to feel
comfortable voting yes on this
thank you madam chair i will only say
that yesterday was the public hearing
on hb2 and the fact that no one chose to
speak about this
is you know that was their choice
and so um when you can't say
we didn't have a public hearing uh we
had the one yesterday
and we also had um
fish and game in to talk to us
and uh
no one from the public commented
and i don't believe that there were any
questions
that were asked about this by
members of the committee and so
i don't think that we can say there
hasn't been
a public hearing and of course
i think that my responsibility
is to make sure that the fish and game
committee
if in fact it had gone to them would
have
approved it and what i got back
from fish and game is yes they would
approve this if they had said no
then i would have recommended that we
representative i have um matt
from the governor's office here to
answer any questions perhaps you could
provide a little bit of
backstory to these sections or context i
think
that would be very helpful that would be
that would be fine
thank you madam chairwoman and good to
see the members of the committee once
more
just to clarify the genesis of this
language this was a direct request
from the fish and game department and
what this language does
is amends an existing statute to clarify
that you must be a commercial or in this
case
engage in the husbandry or sale of at
least a thousand dollars in products
to be eligible to be compensated for
damage
that is directly uh incurred because of
bears
right now anyone whether there be a
commercial entity or a resident
can petition the state to have the state
pay for that damage so this
adds some more guard rails on what types
of
occasions this the state would be in a
position to
pay for that damage and also clarifies
the process
and given it some more uh clearly
defined structures
for how these proceedings uh would occur
and again this all the direct request of
uh representative lynn you had johanna
yes thank you madam chair can i just ask
uh
mr mayor is the idea i mean i i
understand that this
this what we're voting on now didn't
establish this program and i have to be
completely honest with you i had no idea
um uh before i i came across this in the
budget that
that the state was paying these kind of
things to anybody
and so i guess my question is is
is the rationale behind this
that it by offering to pay
people for bear damage the theory is
that they won't resort to self-help and
try to shoot the bear if the bear is
damaging their crop or whatever because
there'll be some some kind of
compensation
uh available i mean is that is that the
rationale
i wouldn't want to speak to that element
i would put that to the fish and game
department on exactly where
this section originated some time ago
um i don't believe that's the intent
here but
i guess to give one example if you have
a bird feeder in your backyard that is
damaged by a bear
right now you can petition the state to
have the state pay for your damaged
bird feeder under this idea
only someone that is you know growing
crops for an agricultural use
or something along those lines would be
eligible to receive compensation so
trying to take away some of those and
i'll admit i didn't know the state did
this either prior to our conversations
with fish and game
um i think the state owes me some money
for some bird feeders in my backyard
over time but nonetheless just
clarifying that if you're a commercial
or industrial entity that suffers damage
there is a process that you can bring
acclaim to the state
but not for some of these uh other
instances and
um yeah i guess i would leave that there
okay well i guess i mean that that is at
least somewhat clarifying to me i
at least i mean i i frankly you know
i on the overall policy issue i guess i
kind of wonder if this
is a good idea at all but i understand
that's you know maybe
it's been in law for quite a while i
mean just as an example i you know
maybe it would make more sense to devote
this kind of money
to the to the uh the fish uh biologists
that
uh that we've basically said we're not
gonna we're not gonna
uh you know we're not there's not enough
money or something for that
um but but i suppose uh
i guess given that it's already been in
law for a long time and this seems to be
at least
reducing the scope of the people who are
entitled to collect
um i i guess i i could i can go along
with it but
uh it i'm still not sure that it's a
very
it this is a the most worthwhile usage
of
of funds even if it is coming from the
fish and game fund
okay uh it appears that bears
are high on the list of things that we
want to argue about
so i think we've spent enough time on
bears today
so mickey would you please
contact the fish and game
uh commissioner i guess he's not called
a commissioner
would you call contact the fish and game
person
and ask him to uh
come and uh and talk to us
about this these particular sections of
uh of hb2
many of you may or may not remember when
fish and game was in i said oh
we're going to have lots of problems
with bears
so if you would do that and
um i uh
i guess we could um
anyhow figure out a figure out the best
time for him and for us
and then um we will uh
we will not discuss any more bears today
if that's okay so
okay is uh representative as long as
oh i wanted to speak more about bears
and more particularly
mountain lions i'm very upset that they
rsa okay
well fish and game says they're no
mountain lions
just in case no no mountain lions in new
hampshire
okay so one
last thing and then um i want to switch
to talking
about the um commission
on uh i'll call it lorry list which of
course is not
but and that is uh
section 134 which
is um the repeal of
uh not the state not taking care of
uh the two roads in uh
in sandwich and thornton
uh i think that
um bill cass indicated
that um he had uh
talked to the selectmen
of these towns and there didn't seem to
be
so uh
does anybody have any problems with
approving this oh thank you
okay could i could i have a motion
to uh accept
uh section 134
moves to uh approve that motion of 134
as long as there's no bear habitat on
okay as far as i know the answer is no
but
i haven't driven on those two roads but
i've been in some pretty scary things in
sandwich so
do i have a second please i can buy
petri okay
thank you uh representative lynn oops we
have a question representative heath
i'm sorry um i remember in the last
session
we had a lot about um this issue
um mickey was all that resolved or
um is this something that that um
didn't get addressed last time and is
i don't recall this specific situation
this is a pretty isolated thing from a
very old law i don't really really
recall anything from last budget
tied into this okay thank you
so there are no issues around this for
not that i'm aware of nor was mr cass
so if you're ready representative lin
please call the role
yes certainly uh uh representative petry
feature votes yes representative
turcotte
representative uh representative lin
votes yes
representative porter order votes yes
representative heath yes representative
murray
mary votes yes and representative umber
representative umberger vote yes all
right voted 7-0 in the affirmative madam
chair
uh
mickey did we make any headway today
or is this no we did so
so this document that you're looking at
and the one that we walked through
before
with the approval of some hb1 items i'll
update those
with the amendments and i'll plug them
into that action column
as well as like just accept for the ones
that we didn't change so when we see a
new document tomorrow
you'll see you know tangibly some of the
work that we got done today so yeah
we're we're moving the right direction
okay representative heath
thank you i just want to say to mickey
thank you for keeping a running
list like this it really is helpful in
our deliberation
well thank you that's for sure
and i understand it's a little tricky
with multiple pdfs and not everyone has
you know six monitors to keep everything
up on and uh
daily mailings to get to you is a little
tricky you know but we're doing our best
and
hopefully this is useful for everybody
i'll tell you what it is certainly
useful for me
and i think it helps us all to uh
stay a little bit organized absolutely
you know instead of wandering all over
the place
but we'll we'll get there
um so i would like to
uh take this down mickey
and go to
section
and through 147.
uh you indicated that
uh okay matt is there
um is steve lavoy on the
call or uh uh
i do i do have steve here if you like
okay
and you're all set with the screen share
you said representative
yeah no we don't we don't need that
1 45
63.
okay and the issue that
um
okay uh
the question is is there anyone
that is opposed to
don't all speak at once
okay when you ask for a little context
if you remember
this is part of that law enforcement
study
that was done and
if i remember correctly they indicated
that um this particular
area that there was not
they still had some work to do and so in
order to do the work
they wanted to establish uh
this commission to um
yes madam chair um i got a
concern about uh the attorney general
making the four appointments
the extras and um
the having the police stands in training
one of those
uh of of those four uh necessary
versus uh the committee making the
decision of who the
can i get clarification on this is in
148 the half a million dollars
because we have the study commission
being formed
the study commission is going to study
whether there should be a commission or
how this commission should look
on the um
the complaints of misconduct and can we
just get uh
refresh me about is that half a million
dollars
is that for the study commission and in
which case why do they need that or is
that for the commission that's actually
going to do the work that deals with a
misconduct
uh yes represent murray
this money was put in
for 23
to actually pay for
i don't myself
i don't believe that we should
attempt to
define the number of people
uh because if it's there and it says
the commission needs five guess what the
commission will do
they'll make it so they need five people
um
myself on this um
i would recommend that we um
put like a hundred thousand dollars in
hb2
eliminate the 500 000 whatever it was
in hb1 and this would
allow them to do whatever they need to
do
plus if you know if they need
whatever their need is that they could
then come to fiscal
and ask for the money at that time
that would be that would be my
recommendation
you know i don't know whether a hundred
thousand dollars is the right number or
not
but a hundred thousand i think comes
close to um
what we would pay a clerk if that's
you know i don't know but that's that's
sort of where
you know what i'm thinking follow-up
absolutely so i'm clear so now i
i think i agree but i still want to make
sure
this money is for the study commission
not the commission that's going to deal
with a misconduct
it's to establish to consider how that
acting committee on the misconduct will
be what it will look like
so it's for the study commission yeah
what we would do
is put it in hb2
under the study commission and allow it
to stay there
for two years so if the study commission
needed it
fine if they didn't then
then whatever they come to grips with
an organization then it could be applied
towards the organization
okay i think i got it thank you all
right representative lin
uh yeah i i think what you propose makes
sense i guess the
the only uh this is really a follow-up
to representative the issue that
representative petrie raised
about we talked about this the other day
that the four
other members of the of the commission
um it doesn't sort of say how they're
appointed
and i i think we might have asked a
question of mr mayo about that and he
was gonna
so maybe he has a he has some further
thoughts on that but my
if he does that's great my thought was
either let's have the governor make that
appointment or let's have the attorney
thank you representative lin for the
question and that those are the two
most logical for us one would be the
governor the other alternative would be
the chair of the we act commission
who could make those appointments and
the chair of that commission
is the attorney general so i think those
are the most
natural people that
you could yeah okay so what
what if i understood what you just said
matt
um
the chair of the liac commission
would appoint the four additional
members
is that correct
i see your head nodding but i'm not
hearing you i'm sorry i was that was
that for me representative umberg i'm
sorry
yes so we would say
uh the chairman of the
leak committee would appoint the four
additional members is that what i heard
you say
you could certainly say that and just so
that the committee is aware
that we act was chaired by the attorney
general
they are not meeting at this point but
they still exist as a chartered
uh by executive order okay so the
executive order is still
okay representative lynn did that answer
your question
yeah i think it did you know my just my
suggestion is that
um rather than i mean i understand that
technically the layout
leak commission is still in existence
um but it sounds like it mostly has
completed its work
so i wonder if it's just in the interest
of making things easier and avoiding
some question
later on if it wouldn't make more sense
to simply say
in that section
105 d3 roman numeral 1
d that four additional members from the
new hampshire commission
on law enforcement accountability um
uh and then two two of these members
shall be law enforcement members and two
of these members shall not be law
enforcement members
and then to just add a sentence saying
these four members shall be appointed by
okay and to
to um representative petrie's
comment um i
i personally agree that
um the police standards and training
person
should in fact be one of the
members of this committee and
um i say that
because they are they are
right now the group that is
reviewing this stuff i mean that's
that's my understanding
and i think that's what mr skipper said
and he has a whole group of people that
uh i don't know what that committee's
called
so um
[Music]
matt do you or steve have any comment on
that
the only thing that i would say is
police standards
is only act so the current language
would
allow them to be appointed out of
those four members the only thing i
would say
is if the committee does start to
identify
a specific agency such as police
standards that department of safety
it would make sense to also delineate
them
but again in both instances those two
agencies are already captured by those
four
right but if the attorney general chose
not to
put someone on there so what you're
what you're saying is that we could say
uh we could do d that says
um or well we could do it in four four
additional members
including a person from safety and a
person
from the police standards and training
and then to
law enforcement members the only other
recommendation i would have would maybe
be to add or essentially
give each give safety and police
standards their own
line and then maybe either reduce that
from four to two
in d uh or or maybe even just increase
the scope of this commission by two but
um those two agencies i would call out
in their own letter
okay okay let's see representative heath
excuse me did you have anything to say
steve
uh no i agree with um with matt's
recommendation
okay all right representative heath i
believe you were next
yes thank you madam chair and thank you
for um
the issue over the police standards i
think that's critically important to
have them
um as part of this i just i'm not sure
and i also agree on reducing the amount
of funding i i don't i think 500 000 is
way too much for this
um my my question
is about the commission
they will do their work they'll come out
with their recommendations
and to whom will these recommendations
go and well will they go to police
standards
and will police standards be the
responsible entity
for training officers across the state
or uh combining just making sure
everybody is fully aware
of what this process is um
and is there a need for any
additional funds for uh communication
of what the work that the commission has
done
or is that something madam chair that
you said that they could come to fiscal
for
so if that's a whole string of questions
thank you
right right i'm happy to answer those
and maybe take this back up to 40 000
feet
so this commission would only exist for
sev for three months if you will they're
going to bring legislation
to the legislature that would recommend
the creation of a new state agency
which is where the 500 000 in the second
year comes from
so no it would not be currently
envisioned to be at police standards and
training
this is in theory a new state agency
that this commission would formalize
through a recommendation to you
the legislature would then vote to
authorize that
and that's how he put aside the 500 000
in year two
just want to and then the commission
goes away
right they're repealed on november 2nd
of this year
so but again this is a new state agency
is the
in theory the final work product of this
did you have a follow-up representative
so what happens to police standards
nothing they nothing happens to police
standards
all right okay but yes um
i would assume that part of
their uh normal training program
that this would be an you know something
that was
uh that was discussed okay
uh let's see represent turcotte were you
next or was it representative porter
go ahead represent turquoise okay thank
you all right just just to be clear this
is the way i read it
we're going to establish a uh commission
as delineated in 105 d3a
that commission is going to run from or
till november first
and november 2nd that commission
will be repealed
it will no longer exist and then
in 148 it's saying that we're going to
uh
appropriate 517 250
and that would be for the commission
delineated in 105 d3a
so the way i'm reading it is that money
is for a period of only up to november
2nd am i correct representative turcotte
what i would point to
is line 8 on page 65
the appropriation is for the purpose of
establishing
this new statewide entity and it's in
fiscal year
23. so the money does not come into play
until the commission has issued its
report
the legislature has considered
legislation next year
if the legislature votes to establish
this entity
this appropriation would be the
operational costs
and on line eight the single neutral
independent statewide entity
is where this appropriation is for in
i do understand what you're saying i
just so you know i don't read it that
way
it's uh i think it could be certainly
that's one of that's one of the reasons
uh representative why i'm
recommending the reduction okay
uh representative porter thank you madam
chair just a couple of things
um back we're going i'm looking back on
line 23 on page 64
where we're talking about the four
additional members of this
commission two of them are members from
law enforcement
and two of them are members of the
public that are not part of law
enforcement
so just so that we know if we if we
set separate lines up one for the um
police standards and one for was it the
other one department of safety
that was the other one then we are
eliminate then
then what would be left would just be
two members
that are not um law enforcement
okay so that's that's the first question
or clarification that i wanted to make
or we could or we could enlarge the
commission by two people
okay thank you and then okay then i'm
confused i guess because on
page 65 at the top line one
section 147 is talking about a million
dollars for cameras
and then we're skipping down to line
five 148
is talking about the commission again to
receive the complaints
nikki is uh in the process of
trying to clean up this area
okay so that we have body cameras with
body cameras
and we have commission with commission
so can i have one more question and then
i'll exactly is that correct mickey
yeah these uh these subjects kind of got
entangled
and built through as it was introduced
so we will untangle them and have
separate amendments
uh for the division thank you and then
just one more
thing please go ahead so and i think i'm
understanding now
that the figure of 517 250 dollars
is in there to fund the new state agency
which would be
uh the complaint agency and what you are
you have recommended representative
umberger is reducing that figure
that's correct okay thank you very much
representative heath you have your hand
up
yes i'm sorry madam chair um i want
clarification about this new agency am i
correct
in assuming this will be an agency
like the child advocates agency
that operates separately without
um beholden to anybody else because
it's totally objective am i right in my
thinking well i believe i know matt was
shaking his head
i believe that that is the current
concept
okay now whether or not that becomes the
reality
out of the study committee i think matt
had made the comment that
there were you know some sticky
wickets that the uh this commission
still needed to work through
uh but overall uh
he thought that i'm putting words in his
mouth i hope you don't mind
uh but overall um
they are leaning towards a
separate entity like the child advocate
or
um whatever else
is that correct matt that is and i just
want to clarify i think that was matthew
broadhead from doj
that referred to those things um but
nonetheless the
okay so um
are there any other comments or
questions that we have on this uh
mickey are you clear enough
to what it appears that we can agree to
to move forward with
yes i believe so it should be good to go
to turn something around
for another work session okay okay
so that um and uh
so if that's if that's the case um we
will
i love just giving mickey all this work
and i apologize
but um it's it's something that we need
to be uh
the other thing that i want to remind
people
is if you have amendments
that you want to put forward
we need to get those um
[Music]
we've got some um some challenges with
time
and having the full committee here in
that
um representative petrie is not going to
be here
tomorrow and representative heath is not
going to be here on monday
so i don't want to put ourselves in a
position
where we are taking votes on either of
those two days
because i i just i don't you know
i don't think it's uh it's appropriate
and fair
that we don't have the full committee to
so that's why i have
we have scheduled uh some more
conversation
on the uh university system and the
community college system
tomorrow uh just to try to iron out
whatever still needs to be ironed out
there
um and so that we can
we can make a decision i did
invite shannon and uh kathy provencher
to come and listen in uh
i really feel that this will be
primarily
but i think uh matt was invited as well
but i i think that we are you know
we need to coalesce around something
uh even if our coalescence is we
agree to disagree okay but that's
that's where we need to uh where we need
to get to
so that will be that will be on uh
tomorrow
and i expect that that will not be a
short discussion
on monday mickey did we
invite any anyone in on monday
we have not officially yet i can tell
you if you
have the appetite for more bear
discussion i do have executive director
scott mason from fish and game ready to
answer any questions you may have
today or we can invite him back for
well as long as he's here i am
i am thrilled to have some more bear
discussions
okay you want to do that now or did you
have any other housekeeping you wanted
to do while you were in the middle of
that i didn't want to cut off
okay no i just the only thing i just
want to make sure
that if people have uh amendments out
there
that we get them so we can look at them
and uh and figure out you know
whatever that we can do so anyhow i was
just going to say
on monday if we can i would like
to have doe
in to talk about
what is currently
in our formula and what is
not compared to two years ago
okay and um because i'm you know i
wasn't
i wasn't there two years ago and
um most of us on the committee were not
so um i just think we need to
clarify all of that and um
see what we what's there so
and i am uh
[Music]
the what's it called
109 billion act um that just passed i'm
sorry i don't recall what it was
what it was dubbed but um
but there are as i understand it
um funds
for education in there that may have
um some impact on
what we do so okay
so uh
mr mason we have had
all kinds of questions about
through 113. on
on bears and um
i can't believe steve is still on the
line
listening to the bears he must have some
in his backyard
the questions are here and so if we
could
i will um maybe
maybe what we ought to do is have you
tell us why you asked
for this particular
these particular sections to go
um currently right now
um i believe new hampshire is one of 13
states that pays for bear damage to
growing
crops
[Music]
we've as our bear population is
increasing we are seeing more
um non-commercial farmers
ask for bear because of the
way law is written is to ask for bear
damage payments
uh what this what this will do is it
will limit it to
folks that are commercially growing
crops in the state of new hampshire
trying to sell crops instead of just for
their own use
um and that's what some of the targets
are it also sets up some
parameters such that they have to
allow one of our fundamental best ways
to control their damage is to allow
hunting on your property
so that becomes one of the issues before
the state would would issue you
a bear damage payment you'd have to
allow hunting on your property
the next step is uh we have some
mitigation practices that we
try to get farmers to um if possible to
try to use
bears respond bears do not like electric
fence
and you can if you are uh if you
create a quality electric fence you can
usually keep bears out of certain areas
i have the unique um experience that
uh having farmed for uh 25 years in
colus county
i've been dealing with bears
commercially for over 25 years and
trying to keep them out of growing crops
so
i have i have experience that i have
experience on both sides of the bear
fence issue
okay uh representative petry you have a
question
yes thank you mr uh madam chair uh it's
a clarification uh now
if a bear does a home in a hungry bear
does a
well let me ask you mean for damage or
for the ability
of the property owner to defend
themselves
that would be damage uh everybody has a
right to defend themselves i believe
correct
uh so no we do the the state does not
cover
damage only to growing crops right
that's correct yes
mark ellingwood with me here in the
office
and i believe kathy's on a phone
someplace too if we have financial
questions
if i um representative may i speak
briefly to put a little
so i just mentioned that the laws in
question were established
in the late 1890s presumably to protect
a very scarce beer resource at the time
we've continued to work very closely
using technical services and monetary
payment
with a particular focus on agriculture
in recent decades there's been a
significant proliferation of
interest in filing for claims by
the general public often involved in
hobby activities
i think a primary thrust of this change
would be to help near our focus so we
can work
with the people who we believe have the
greatest need
and are generally employing the best
practices to prevent bear damage
so that that in a nutshell i think helps
you to understand
why we're advocating for this as it
exists
laws would allow anybody with
any of the protected commodities those
being
crops bees livestock
there's a couple more help me out dan
but in any case it's a small number of
items that qualify and yet
people uh may or may not be exercising
appropriate stewardship
and at the same time have the privilege
through existing law established 120
years ago
to file for damage against the state so
we thought it was time to tighten that
up a bit
and focus on our primary constituency
here
in terms of damage that being the
commercial agriculture
thank you uh representative porter you
had a question
no i think my question was answered
thank you madam chair i'll put my hand
down
thank you uh representative lynn i
believe you are next
thank you so i i i guess i'm
i mean i i guess i'm prepared to support
this because it
it is narrowing this the category of
people who get paid but
i get i'm it sounds like when this was
when this program was
originally established 120 years ago the
idea was to protect the bears because
there weren't very many of them and we
wanted to we wanted to save them
but now the idea if i'm understanding
correctly is there are too many bears
and so we want to have them hunted in
fact in order to get this money
you have to agree to allow hunting on
your
on your property so i guess my question
is wouldn't it
if you to the extent that you're paying
anything
it would seem to me that that's that
that is um
is sort of undercutting the idea of of
uh of of uh encouraging the bears to be
taken because
the the uh the the idea would would seem
to be if i'm gonna get paid
if i'm going to get paid for the crop
damage i would be less
in less inclined to allow
uh to to want to uh have the bears
uh taken than if i wasn't getting paid
at all so i mean then then that would
seem to be to be even a greater
encouragement to allow hunting on your
property
if you're not going to get paid at all
so why not just
stop the payments altogether yeah thank
you representative
i'll respond to that uh
we have more bears than we had we don't
generally have too many bears although
that's debatable depending on your
sensitivity to
the presence of bears um our experience
is that this is a helpful and i think
legitimate interest
of new hampshire agriculture and so much
as some of this damage cannot be avoided
and in certain years particularly when
there's a scarcity of natural foods
some farm interests are subject to
significant impacts and uh
in that context i just say we're content
with the balance
our experience in working with
agriculture is um
none of them are motivated by the the
payments we make the payments tend to be
very conservative we're paying wholesale
values in the field
it certainly would better serve the
interest of the farmer to have no damage
than to have the modest payments that we
allocate so i think we've struck the
right balance the
the other thing is that uh the farm
bureau is a close partner of ours
somebody who we work very closely with
and quite honestly we're not anxious to
to separate or lose the ability to help
them where legitimate
needs exist so
another point i would make to you just
for your background is that these
funds are paid losses are paid
annually through fish fishing game but
charged against
new hampshire general fund money so we
are not
losing that money from fish and game
funds specifically rather the
bill as as directed by the statute
actually is charged against available
state revenues
thank you thank you very much that was
very helpful i appreciate that thank you
you're welcome thank you uh scott you
said
uh kathy was on the line
i i would just like i don't know if i
don't know if mickey
opened up a channel to her or not but
she's in her office
okay i just yeah i was just curious as
to what that dollar figure was
so the totals over the years starting
2011 um they let's
just go let's just go for you know the
last
four years we don't need to go back in
uh 10 742 dollars in
eighteen eighty thousand seven hundred
and sixty seven
nineteen twenty three thousand two sixty
three
twenty fifty seven two thirteen
so you see the cycle that tends to
follow if and we break the we break
these payments down by
by commodity crop you know uh uh um
forage corn um uh
fruit livestock and and um honey damage
and what you
if you look at them what you really
start seeing when you look closely is
is the damage to field corn and that
follows
the bear's natural feed so on a year
where we're seeing a lot more damage in
the field corn
it's because the bears don't have as
much to eat out in the woods
and they've learned to you know come out
of the woods and head into the
cornfields and
representative turcotte you have a
question thank you uh
i answered one of my two questions
uh on the dollar value the other
question is how many incidents or
of filings do you have annually
i i can handle it if you'd like but yeah
it's uh
it's quite small actually you're talking
about a dozen
10 to 20 a year depending on the
commodity
um most as the director indicated most
those funds go
directly to uh to uh corn growers silage
corn and sweet corn
and uh the number in terms of
non-commercial complaints uh they range
on the order of a dozen to 20 a year
and tend to be primarily backyard
chicken growers and some
beekeep bee hive keepers we get an
occasional claim for the loss of a goat
or a pig
from residential communities uh
from bears as well but it's it's modest
representative petrie you have your
you have a question yes i do i well it's
uh
yes uh wild boar in the western part of
the state they caused quite a bit of
damage that i've heard
and why wouldn't a program like this
cover the damage that they do
the liability for damage covered by wild
boar which to our knowledge are
exclusively from blue mountain forest
fall to the forest and they readily
cover that damage
um the the narrow focus of the statutes
a reflection of the
writers of that statute back in the
1890s
it has been changed periodically in
subtle ways as i understand it since
then
did you have a follow-up no i'm all set
uh that's just the way the law is
written and uh
by the way i love your bow kathy
okay are there any other questions
on this is there
anyone that is still
111 through
yes ma'am i was gonna say i'm this the
answers completely satisfy me so i would
i would make a motion to approve uh the
changes as as proposed second at motion
right does anyone have anything they'd
so representative lynn when you're ready
to
call call the vote press
on thank you uh representative petry
vitro votes yes representative turka
representative lin votes yes uh
representative porter yes
representative heath yes
representative murray murray votes yes
and representative umberger
representative umberger votes yes
all right madam chair the vote is six to
okay thank you very much so
um well we got the bears out of the way
today
i knew it i just knew it so anyhow
we will um oh reps on porter did you
have a question or a comment
i was just thinking that i kind of feel
like being at town meeting
where we passed the you know two million
dollar budget
in five minutes and we spend an hour and
oh well the the fun of um
what goes on in the state of new
hampshire
so uh we will um
recess for today
and um come back tomorrow morning
at 10 o'clock to um
do the uh some more
conversation on the on the university
system
mickey do you have anything that you
would like to
say no just a reminder get any
amendments you want to propose
to me and then also uh just let me know
you know we'll we'll communicate
obviously at that point but i just want
to make it clear
that you do want to offer an amendment
before i add it to these working
documents so
um i won't add anything to this until
you know we have those discussions
individually madam chair can i just
just a reminder as i i think i mentioned
to you before i
i will be able to join the meeting but
only for a very few minutes because i
have to go to concord
for the hearing on uh uh
the attorney general nomination um i've
been asked i've been asked to testify
um so i'm gonna i'll be leaving to do
that
that's tomorrow right that's tomorrow
yes
okay uh bob if you do have anything that
you still need clarification on
the uh university system just send me a
note
and i'll make sure it gets asked
yeah no actually i i don't think i do i
mean i understand that there are
you know considerations on both sides of
this but i i
i don't think i really have any
questions but thank you
okay so we'll see everyone tomorrow
morning
at uh 10 o'clock and the
this meeting is recessed until then
so have a good afternoon everybody you
also bye-bye